forensic experts from colombia's peace
tribunal are unearthing mass graves near
the northwest town of the baba
army officers have testified that at
least 50 people
killed by soldiers and falsely presented
as rebel fighters to boost statistics
are buried here
already 54 bodies have been recovered
but only four identified
the burials denied for more than two
decades after one of the darkest
chapters of the country's civil conflict
my uncle eliessa de jesus disappeared in
1997.
until today 2020 that means that we
looked for him for 23 years
family members line up to give blood
samples to help
identify the dead through dna matching
manuel david and his daughter adriana
are still looking for
three of manuel's children
perhaps we'll find one of the bodies
find out where they are
one thing is to know where they are
buried give them a funeral
another is having no idea of what
happened to them
official estimates say that some 200 000
bodies still need to be discovered in
colombia
it's just one of many tasks that the
peace tribunal is addressing
as the country tries to face its past
the act that congregates us here in dead
abiba central park goes beyond returning
these bodies to their family it
reiterates our unwavering commitment
with truth and justice
yet the tribunal created under the 2016
peace accord with farc rebels
has been at the center of political
attacks
some criticize the fact that former
rebels who tell the truth and compensate
victims can avoid prison terms
others believe the tribunal is biased
against the military
and politicians allegedly involved in
war crimes
former president has been leading the
charge
recently calling for a referendum to
abolish the court altogether
but some observers say what critics fear
the most is the unveiling of evidence
showing collusion between the military
paramilitary and powerful elites
former president and those who are
his allies fear the truth
that can emerge from the proceedings of
the
heb the special jurisdiction of peace
and also
from the truth commission but for
millions of victims of colombia's long
internal conflict
this is the first real opportunity to
get a glimmer of
justice and relief alessandro
al jazeera bogota